it was a hard time for both of us I
think because I think it goes back to us
having to constantly compare each other
yeah
[Music]
I am Mattias odd and I am here with my
sister I'm Katya Stan and I'm her sister
but I'd say the relationship is good and
when it's not good we're very honest we
are gone in August I'll forget it
what is your favorite memory of us
growing up Disneyland the two of us went
to Disneyland I just remember you
running around saying there's magic
everywhere right and we would get
chocolate-covered strawberries yeah for
breakfast lunch and dinner that was
really good I was a good two days do you
think our parents treated us equally I
think I noticed that they liked that I
was thinner mm-hm and I would have break
my heart when you were upset you know
yeah it really made me upset yeah mm-hmm
it was a hard time for both of us I
think because I think it goes back to us
having to constantly compare each other
yeah because we are so close in age
mm-hmm people would compare us a lot
physically but it's also it's just not
fair to put that on children to reward
or to shame cuz I felt like I had I felt
very protective of you Hey I didn't know
how to like help you through it
you have a Kinston Yetta there's a lot
of pressure to look good in the dress I
didn't feel like it was fair to you and
I didn't and I didn't know how to jump
in there you know it's just not fair so
yeah I felt as the sister like how do I
say like playing goalie like how do I
protect her from an inevitable event aha
me now yeah okay it's my turn okay do
you think our relationship has changed
since we were kids
yes I do think our relationship has
changed
it's changed for the better I think one
of the big changes is when we live
together oh yeah and we realized that
living together as sisters and being
friends was not gonna happen and I think
that's when we knew like we have to
refigure mm-hmm things out describe a
time you felt like I wasn't there for
you I think I think I was mad when we
lived together that you didn't you
didn't understand me what I was going
through and I felt really hurt by that I
mean I think at that time I I felt the
same thing like you don't understand
what I'm hearing it when I'm going for
yeah and I think we did feel kind of
like maybe it's better we just keep it
really surface for a while and I was
also going through I'd like moved to LA
and all my dreams were broken and it
just sucked I think I felt a little
abandoned I feel like where I feel like
we're still climbing way back to each
other in a little more but with the new
respect that the other person has laid
out yeah yeah
do you have any regrets on anything
you've done to me
ah do I regret so when you move to LA
for the first time and you were going
through a rough time you were looking to
me to throw a rap and I I did instead of
saying like I just don't know what rap
to throw you
you thought I just didn't want to throw
you on like just because I was going
through my own phase at the time of
dealing with issues with the family and
college and I was like I just don't know
what to do so I'm sorry I didn't make
that clear okay
[Laughter]
[Music]